Hey, smartless listeners. It's John Gabris, one of the hosts of Staying Alive, a health and wellness podcast hosted by the unhealthy and unwell. That's Adam Pally and I. And we've got Will Arnett on our pod today. We got to spend some QT interviewing our pod father. And we went deep with him about his this thing on, Bradley Cooper, eating right, fitness, sugar, all the stuff we cover on our show. So please enjoy the first part of the interview with Will. And if you like what you hear, come on over to staying live and hear the second half hit subscribe or follow while you're there
嘿，smartless 的听众们。我是约翰·加布里斯 (John Gabris)，是《保持活着》(Staying Alive) 的主持人之一，这是一档由不健康、不舒服的人主持的健康与养生播客。也就是亚当·帕利 (Adam Pally) 和我。今天我们把威尔·阿奈特 (Will Arnett) 请到了节目上。我们花了一些宝贵的时间采访了我们的“播客教父”。我们跟他深入聊了这部新片、布莱德利·库珀 (Bradley Cooper)、健康饮食、健身、糖分，以及我们在节目中讨论的所有话题。所以请欣赏对威尔的采访的第一部分，如果你喜欢听的话，快来《保持活着》听听下半部分吧，顺便点个订阅或关注。
Hey Will Thanks for thanks for doing this Oh dude thank you So much gents How you doing? Dude you look you look awesome Look that facial hair Really? Oh thanks
嘿，威尔！谢谢，谢谢你抽空来。噢，老兄，非常感谢！各位大佬好。你们最近怎么样？老兄，你看起来气色真好。看那胡子。真的吗？噢，谢谢。
Yeah you got some you got Tony Stark Sean yeah you got some son And you got some Ironman fucking Yeah I was just shipwrecked Nice Dude well You don't hear about it that often anymore about people being shipwrecked. It's fucking old school.
对，你有点托尼·斯塔克（钢铁侠）的范儿。没错，对，有点太阳照射的感觉。还有点钢铁侠他妈的……对，我刚刚遭遇了海难。太棒了！老兄，现在不怎么常听到有人遭遇海难了。这太老派了。
But I knew I had to do staying alive. So I paddled to shore to make sure I did this stupid fucking podcast. I hope that the intro music, are we allowed to play other artists intro music or it just has to be ours? I think we should keep it to be just ours. Oh, okay. So it would be cool if today we could play something from Bruce Springsteen because the boss is here. Yes, our boss is here.
但我知道我必须做《Staying Alive》。所以我划船到岸边，确保我能做这个该死的蠢播客。我希望开场音乐，我们能用其他艺人的开场音乐吗？还是必须只能用我们自己的？我觉得我们还是用我们自己的吧。哦，好吧。那今天如果能放一点布鲁斯·斯普林斯汀 (Bruce Springsteen) 的歌就好了，因为“老板”来了。没错，“老板”来了。
He does not like, we will learn that he does not like to be called the boss, but he is our pod father. He is the boss. Will Arnett on the podcast today. Big guess, so we're not going to go into a long, cold open, because we don't want to turn off anyone who's here to hear Will and not understand that. It's for anyone new. Welcome.
他不喜欢——我们一会儿就会知道——他不喜欢被称为“老板”，但他确实是我们的“播客教父”。他就是“老板”。威尔·阿奈特今天做客播客。这是一位大咖，所以我们不会搞太长的热身开场，因为我们不想惹恼任何专门为了听威尔、却不了解情况的人。对任何新听众说声：欢迎。
We hope that you can learn a little something about what it takes to stay alive as you get older and you don't necessarily play by the rules all the time. Yeah. Well, without further adieu, I'm learning French. Will Arnett. Is that your next duolingo? Trio lingo. No. The podcast lately, I've been feeling a little podcast burn lately. I've just, oh yeah? Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah? I know, of course not, advertisers. We love it. But it's so. I made a joke. Working your ass off? I mean,
我们希望你能从中学到一点东西，关于随着年龄增长、并且不一定总按规矩办事时，如何保持活力。是的。好吧，废话少说（我在学法语），威尔·阿奈特。那是你的下一个多邻国（Duolingo）计划吗？三邻国。不是的。最近做播客，我最近感觉有点播客倦怠了。我只是……哦，是吗？噢，是吗？噢，是吗？我知道，广告商们，当然不是。我们很喜欢。但这太……我开个玩笑。累死累活？我是说，
it's, I did this podcast with this guy in the UK. He's so fun. I mean, I forget how long ago was like, uh,
这……我在英国和这伙计做过这个播客。他太有趣了。我是说，我忘了是多久以前了，大概……
whatever, a couple months ago. And, uh, do you know this dude, Ramesh? Yeah, he's so funny.
不管怎样，几个月前吧。而且……你认识这家伙拉梅什（Ramesh）吗？对，他太有趣了。
He's really, really funny. So he's this podcast. And he asked me, and I told him this, like, I have this controversial position. I said,
他真的、真的很搞笑。所以他是做这个播客的。他问我，我告诉了他这个，就像我有一个很有争议的观点。我说，
there's a direct relationship. Yeah. And I said, the more text. It came up on my feet. The more. tattoos you are the more you have the more boring you are. Now, I was very clear. A, it's something that I've said to my friends with, I don't have any, that I've said to my friends with tattoos for years.
这之间有直接的联系。对。我说，纹身越多……这事儿在我动态里出现了。纹身越多……你有纹身越多，你就越无聊。现在，我当时说得非常清楚。A，这是我多年来一直对我有纹身的朋友们说过的话——我其实没有纹身——
And it's, and it's basically a bit, right? Yeah. When I say it with it, that people are freaking out in the comments and the thing. And then I'm like, what a boring response. If you're, if you're insulted by it, then you're proving my point. But the truth is, I don't have a point. I didn't even mean it because I have a million friends who were covered with tattoos. And, People are insulted by it. It's insanity, man. Yeah, it's crazy when you realize that bullshit is news. Like, all of a sudden you're like, Will Arnett says they did have a guy on smart list that they didn't air or whatever.
而且这、这基本上是一个梗，对吧？对。当我这么说的时候，评论区和各种地方的人都抓狂了。然后我想：多么无聊的反应啊。如果你、如果你被这话冒犯了，那你就正好证明了我的观点。但事实是，我根本没有观点。我甚至不是认真的，因为我有一百万个朋友身上都纹满了身。然后，人们却被冒犯了。这太疯狂了，老兄。是的，当你意识到这种狗屁居然也能算作新闻时，这真的很疯狂。就像，突然之间你会发现：威尔·阿奈特说……他们之前在 smartless 上也有过一个人，但没播出来或者别的什么。
This goes everywhere and you're like, who is, who is this matter to? What doesn't matter to Will? Have you looking at? It doesn't matter to me at all. But matters to podcasts. Most of them are bits. Most of them are just to fuck around in the moment, right? And then you're like, and then you hold it up.
这消息传得到处都是，然后你会想：这到底关谁屁事？这关威尔什么事？你在看什么？这对我一点都不重要。但对播客来说……大多数都是梗。大多数都只是为了当时开开玩笑，对吧？然后你会想，然后你把它拿出来——
Let's read this back in court. So your theory on tattoo, it was not a theory. It's a bit. You said here you like, you love to go swimming with bow-legged women. Is that correct? It's like, I was quoting a fucking movie. I did it. Anytime you get like even do it, this is all a net loss.
“让我们在法庭上宣读这段话。”所以你关于纹身的理论……那不是理论。是个梗。你这里说你喜欢跟罗圈腿的女人一起游泳？是这样吗？这就像，我当时在引用一部该死的电影！我做了。任何时候只要你稍微……这绝对是得不偿失。
Like this can only hurt. This can only hurt. That's why we are so thankful that you're coming on our podcast because it's only, it's just lost. Yeah. It's just a fucking mindfield of like... That's a very loose. How are... Well, if you're not our boss, that means rich is our boss,
这只会造成伤害。这只会带来伤害。这就是为什么我们这么感激你来我们的播客，因为这纯粹是……这只会带来损失。是的。这简直就是个地雷阵……这是一个非常宽松的……怎么……威尔，如果你不是我们的老板，那就意味着里奇（Rich）是我们的老板，
and that is a problem. That is... You're right, by the way, that's a problem for everybody. If you prefer the term podfather, we could do that too. Oh, I like that. You know what I wanted to ask you?
那这就成问题了。那是……顺便说一句，你说得对，这对每个人来说都是个问题。如果你更喜欢“播客教父”这个称呼，我们也可以叫那个。哦，我喜欢这个。你知道我想问你什么吗？
Will, like, is... Please be about tattoos. No, it's not... You're talking to guys who have matching tattoos. We are wildly... I can go fuck about when I saw that he was like you know what he's kind of right I am a drag I like
威尔，就像……千万别是关于纹身的。不，不是……你在跟两个有着情侣纹身的人说话。我们极其……我看到那个的时候差点笑死，他当时就像是：你知道吗？他说的有点道理。我确实挺无聊的，我喜欢……
my head goes instantly to because now you're like a dramatic bleeding man is to what like do you feel how are you thin how are you looking like this Oh, oh, oh, physically. Oh, yeah. Like how, because our show is about staying alive, like,
我的脑子立刻转到了……因为你现在就像是一个戏剧性的、浑身流血的男人，在想：像什么……你感觉怎么样？你现在多瘦？你现在看起来怎么样？哦，哦，哦，身体上。哦，是的。像怎么……因为我们的节目是关于保持活力的，就像……
because we're too out of shape or better in shape now. Yeah. We're doing pretty good. I don't know if it's the show or like dark medical revelations in our lives. You guys look good. Yeah. We're a better place. I'm like down 20 pounds.
是因为我们身材走样了，还是现在身材变好了？是的。我们现在状态挺好的。我不知道是因为节目，还是因为我们生活中的重大医疗警示。你们看起来不错。是的。我们现在状态好多了。我瘦了差不多20磅。
You see? Yeah. I'm under 300 for the first time in like 10 years. It feels amazing. I might have to start buying a new. budgie smugglers. But like, so what are you doing to stay alive? Like, are you, because I have a text exchange that you and I have that I found on my phone
你看？对。我十年里第一次体重降到了300磅以下。感觉太棒了。我可能得开始买新的“泳裤”了。但是，那么你都在做些什么来保持活力呢？比如说，因为我手机里存着你和我的一段聊天记录，
today from over the summer that I could read to you. We might have to edit? I don't think we do. It's pretty, I don't think we do. Okay. It's pretty base and it heads into the question. It starts with Long Island, baby, where are you at? headed to Ruby Rosa to eat my weight in red sauce.
那是今年夏天我今天刚翻到的，我可以读给你听。我们可能得剪掉？我觉得不用吧。这挺……我觉得不用。好吧。这挺接地气的，而且直接切入正题。开头是：长岛宝贝，你在哪儿？正赶往鲁比罗莎（Ruby Rosa）吃掉我体重的红酱。
What are you doing? No can do on pizza, but let's hang out this week. Then I wrote back, what are you doing to keep that Walton Goggins physique? And then you wrote back, you wrote back, I start by not eating, then I smoke a couple butts,
你准备干嘛？披萨绝对不行，不过这周我们聚聚吧。然后我回道：你都在做些什么来保持沃尔顿·戈金斯（Walton Goggins）那种体型的？然后你回我，你回道：我先靠不吃东西开始，然后抽几根烟，
repeat every day. And as always, we are not doctors on this show. Do not take any medical advice. And as someone who struggles with everything, including the smoking. Yeah. I'm blood type marinara at this point. So I get it. I'm, yeah, it's that old school diet, man.
每天重复。一如既往，我们在节目中不是医生。请不要采取任何医疗建议。作为一个跟所有事情都在作斗争的人，包括抽烟。是的。我现在的血型基本上是玛丽娜拉红酱了。所以我懂。我、是的，就是那种老派的减肥法，老兄。
I've just, right. I look, I look, I think a lot of people, I look like that dude who, like, now that I'm looking on the thing here, I look like that dude who's like kind of tan and smokes butts. and drinks coffee. I became that. Place plays chess. I became the guy that I used to go to my buddies. Hey, look at that guy.
我只是……对。我看起来……我觉得很多人，我看起来就像那种……现在我看着这上面的画面，我看起来就像那种晒得古铜、抽着烟、喝着咖啡的家伙。我变成了那样的人。下下棋。我变成了我以前会指着朋友说：“嘿，看那个家伙”的那种人。
Right. We all do. That's who I aspire to be. Look at me. I look like fucking Mark Maren drowned in a pool. Yeah. I look like an offensive lineman in court for a fucking D-2-I. I.
对。我们都这样。那曾是我渴望成为的人。看看我。我看起来就像个淹死在游泳池里的马克·马龙（Mark Maren）。对。我看起来就像一个因为酒驾而出庭的美式足球进攻锋线球员。
I locked the gates. How come you didn't lock the gates? I drowned in the pool. Jesus Christ. Jesus. I, you know what the truth is about, what are we? About 18 months ago, one of my agents was like
我把门锁上了。你为什么不把门锁上？我淹死在游泳池里了。天哪。天哪。我，你知道关于……真相是什么？我们大概在……18个月前，我的一个经纪人说：
hey you should go talk to this doctor like out of the blue not out of the blue for you but that's something that was on the agents mind I was ever out of the blue meanwhile like the CIA
嘿，你应该去看看这个医生。简直是突发奇想。也不是突发奇想，对你来说不是，但这是经纪人操心的事。我可从没觉得是突发奇想，与此同时就像中情局
had a morning meeting about my weight and and they go and he goes you should go see this dude who's basically like a nutritionist and talking he's like what he's like what do so I was so and that's a true story
开了一个关于我体重的早会，然后他们说……然后他说：你应该去看看这家伙，他基本上就像个营养师，聊一聊。他说他怎么怎么样。所以我当时就……这是一个真实的故事。
And I was like, you know, I think I always was able to stay thin and then I got over 50. And as you know, like, it just gets hard. When you're over 50, it's just, and they're like, sorry, I'm going to eat what I want, but I'll just work out. And then you just get massive. So, so I was like, what do I do? So I went to see this guy and he helped me look at the stuff I was eating. And he was like, okay.
然后我想，你知道，我以前一直都能保持苗条，然后我过了50岁。正如你们所知，这就变得很难了。当你过了50岁，这简直……他们会说，抱歉，我想吃什么就吃什么，我只要多锻炼就行了。然后你就会变得体型庞大。所以，所以我就想：我该怎么办？于是我去看这个人，他帮我审视了我吃的东西。他说，好吧。
And like, you know, you tell him, he's like, how, what do you, you know, you tell him, like, it's not that bad. And then you tell him, he's like, wow, that's terrible. And you're like, oh, shit, really? The worst with those kind of situations is when you downplay what you're doing and they still say it's bad. You're like, yeah, I have like two beers
而且，你知道，你告诉他，他会问：你都吃些什么？你知道，你告诉他时，会说“其实没那么糟”。然后你告诉他之后，他会说：哇，这太糟糕了。然后你会想：哦，靠，真的吗？这种情况下最糟糕的是，你把自己的行为轻描淡写，而他们还是说这很糟糕。你会觉得：是的，我一周有几个晚上会喝个两杯啤酒。然后他们会说：那真的很糟糕。我就想：哦，我已经开始撒谎了。这才是最好的部分。我几年前戒酒的时候就干过这事。我当时对这个家伙说，我去看这个医生，我看得出来，我就说——这大概是90年代初吧——
like a couple of nights a week and they're like, that's really bad. I'm like, oh, I was lying already. That's the good. I did that once years ago when I used to drinking this guy said I went to this doctor and I could tell and I go, this is like early 90s
他问我：你喝多少酒？我说——我在琢磨这算多还是少——我大概一周喝六杯吧。他说：那可真不少。而我心里想：你他妈的，那是我出门前要喝的六杯。
and he goes, how much do you drink and I said, and I'm thinking like, when is going to be? I go probably six drinks a week. He's like, that's a lot. And I'm thinking, motherfucker, that's before I go out. I have six drinks.
那是一天的量。是的。亚当和我非常习惯于告诉医生“我不抽烟”，每当他们不得不抽烟的时候。我甚至连这个都做不到了。我退步了。我退步了，所以连这个都做不到了。现在我在对新西兰的一个医生撒谎说我不抽烟，当时他正在给我做体检。我坐在那种……为了去见医生，好像医生待会儿要进来。
That's a day. Yeah. Adam and I are very adjusted to telling a doctor, not cigarettes whenever they have to smoke. And I can't even do that anymore. I've regressed. I've regressed so I can't even do that anymore. Now I'm lying about cigarettes to a doctor in New Zealand who's like filling out a physical. I'm like sitting in like the in order to get to set that like a doctor's going to come in here.
你觉得这样行吗？我就说：行吧，随便。那家伙进来了。他说，上面写着你……一天抽三到五杯酒。我就说：我没有。不，我不知道。我不知道。
You all right with that? I'm like, yeah, whatever. Guy comes in. He's like, says he. three to five drinks a day. I was like, I don't. No, I don't know. I don't know.
我甚至都没填那个。那是别人写的。那是别人看到我的时候瞎猜的。好吧，这下面用的是公制，对吧？所以，是的，其实数量不一样。对，而且“一天”是指明天，因为明天就是我们的昨天。所以我，是的。
I didn't even fill that out. Somebody else wrote that. Someone else guessed that when they saw me. Well, it's metric down here, right? So, yeah, it's not actually the same amount. Yeah, and a day, you mean tomorrow, because tomorrow is our yesterday. So I'm, yeah.
哦，我们不用时区吗？好吧。接下来的事就是，他开始像写精神病病例一样写东西。边缘型人格障碍。对，边缘型的。而且，所以真相其实是……所以，我最终基本上戒了糖，这是我的头号……我觉得是我的头号瘾，因为我戒不了烟。是烟对我有瘾。
Oh, we're not doing time zones? Okay. Next thing I know, he's like writing like psycho. Catholic conversation. Borderline personality disorder. Yeah, borderline. I, and so the truth is actually, so I, I, I ended up cutting up basically sugar, which is my number one, I think my number one addiction, because I won't, because I'm not addicted to cigarettes. And they're addicted to me.
你太牛逼了。我和烟是协同作用的。我们互相帮助。它们从来没让我失望过。它们从来没对我说过谎。它们总是告诉我它们要做什么。从你认识它们的那一刻起，你就对它们死心塌地……
You're such a badass And I are synergistic We help each other They've never let me down They've never lied to me They always told me what they were gonna do You are like blind to you from the moment You know
我知道。我本来想说……就像糖一样。当你拒绝糖的时候……你是说多严格？你是说像……你出去吃寿司时吃刺身吗？基本上是的。
I know I was gonna say like sugar When you say no sugar Like how strict are we talking Are we talking like no like You go out to sushi You're doing sashimi Yeah basically
当我真的严格执行的时候。所以我去吃。哦，天哪，这太无聊了。但我吃。我知道。而且，我们有点生活在一个无聊的世界里。所以别介意。我有一堆纹身，老兄。
When I'm really doing it And so I go, I eat. Oh, God, it's so boring. But I eat. I know. Also, we're kind of living in the boring world. So don't let it. I got a bunch of tattoos, man.
这就是我喜欢的东西。你说得对。这太棒了。太棒了。你就像是在说：我讨厌这段流传出去的言论，我们在一个采访里已经提了11次了。不，我喜欢它，因为它太蠢了，因为它毫无意义。拉梅什自己都快笑死了。
This is the shit I'm into. You're right. It's so good. It's so good. You're like, I hated that this blurb went around and we've brought it up 11 times one interview. No, I love it because it's so dumb because it was so meaningless. Romesh is laughing himself.
你知道我从那个剪辑里看出了什么吗？就像，拉梅什当时像是：我有好多纹身啊。我很无聊吗？我当时真想说：不，但是那个苹果手表（Apple Watch）让你显得更无聊了。我们应该……纹身挺好的。是苹果手表的问题。
You know what I took from that clip? It's like, Romesh is like, he's like, I have a lot of tattoos. Am I boring? And I wanted to be like, no, but the Apple Watch is making you more. We should be. Tattoes are fine. It's the Apple Watch.
所以你戒了糖。所以基本上……我有那么难吗？你有过吗？有什么为你自己做的事吗？比如有什么替代品之类的……
So you cut out sugar. So I basically, like I was that difficult? Like, do you have any hat? Anything that you did for yourself? Like any substitutes or anything like that? that we're like... Dude, dude, I'm addicted to ice cream. I fucking love ice cream.
老兄，老兄，我对冰淇淋上瘾。我他妈太爱冰淇淋了。
My favorite. It's my fucking favorite. So I'm like, like every day for me is like a nine-year-old's birthday party leading up to this. Every day, you'd be like, what are you doing? And so I had to like go, so I had to go... To answer your question, I couldn't, I didn't even go for sushi because I kind of, I was too nervous that I wanted to eat the rice.
我的最爱。这是我他妈的最爱。所以我感觉……对我来说，每天都像是一个九岁小孩的生日派对，一直在为此做准备。每天，你都会想：你在干嘛呢？所以为了回答你的问题，我甚至连寿司都不敢去吃，因为我太担心自己会忍不住去吃米饭了。
Right? So then I just, so every day I'd wake up. And eventually I started, I was doing like, I was do like a little bit of oats and then some berries and whatever. And then like a little snack. And then lunch, I have a salad with chicken. And then at dinner, I have to have like 18 ounces of protein, fish or meat and some veggies. And then actually there's a crazy thing here. So I did that.
对吧？所以后来我只能……所以我每天醒来……最后我开始吃一点燕麦，然后加一些浆果，诸如此类。然后加一点零食。午餐我吃鸡肉沙拉。然后晚餐我必须吃大约18盎司的蛋白质，鱼肉或肉类，还有一些蔬菜。然后这里其实有个疯狂的事情。所以我照做了。
And then eventually he, and I could have a cup of rice with lunch. Then he got, and then like 45 days into it, he's like, now you got to cut all the carbs. So now I have none. And I don't have a cheat day. have a cheap meal once a week. Every seven days I have one cheap meal. Jesus. Yeah, and he's like, don't go downtown on your go uptown,
然后最后他……我午餐可以吃一杯米饭。然后他接着说，在进行了大约45天之后，他说：现在你得把所有的碳水化合物都戒了。所以现在我什么碳水都没有了。我没有作弊日（cheat day）。我一周只有一顿作弊餐（cheat meal）。每七天我有一顿作弊餐。天哪。
meaning like don't eat a bunch of crap on your cheap meal. Don't go to like Taco Bell and McDonald's. Right. Have a nice dessert. Yeah, have a nice dessert that doesn't have like a bunch of preservatives in it. And so I've kind of stayed to that for the last year and a half. And I've had a couple times where I haven't been able to. But for the most part, I've stuck with it and exercised at the same time.
对，他说：别去吃那些垃圾食品，吃点高档的。意思是别在作弊餐时吃一堆垃圾。别去塔可钟（Taco Bell）和麦当劳。对。吃个好点的甜点。对，吃个没有一堆防腐剂的好甜点。所以我差不多坚持了一年半。中间有几次没能坚持下来。但大部分时间我都坚持下来了，同时还坚持锻炼，
and it's been pretty good. Here's a cool thing that he taught me. What kind of exercise are we doing? I just do, you know, street fighting mainly. A lot of street fighting. Yeah, your Kimbo slice in the backyards of Florida. It's hard to find a good gym. It's hard to find a good gym.
效果相当不错。这里有个他教我的很酷的事情。我们都在做什么锻炼？我主要就是做……你知道，街头格斗。大量的街头格斗。对，你是佛罗里达州后院的金博·斯莱斯（Kimbo Slice）。很难找到一个好健身房。很难找到一个好健身房。
It's easy to find a street fight. I'm doing, you know, I do pretty light in terms of the gym. Pretty light. I was doing this thing where I was like, And I do it I don't do it as much anymore just because of time or whatever, but I was doing this boxing thing called Fight Camp
但找一场街头格斗很容易。我在做……你知道，我在健身房里的训练相当轻松。相当轻松。我曾经做过一件事，而且……我现在不怎么做了，主要是因为时间或者别的什么，但我以前做过一种叫 Fight Camp 的拳击训练，
and Thoreau turned me on to it and it's like you get like a, it's almost like Peloton for boxing. I look like the loserist boxer of all time. Oh, I'm the worst in that. I'm the worst in there. But the cardio of it was really great. So I do that a couple days a week. I do these like sort of long walks and or hikes and then I do stuff with like kettlebell. Pretty light stuff.
梭罗（Thoreau）向我推荐的，它就像是一个……几乎就是拳击界的 Peloton（健身单车）。我看起来像是有史以来最失败的拳击手。哦，我在那里面是最差的。我在里面是最差的。但它的有氧运动效果真的很棒。所以我一周做几次那个。我做这种长时间的散步和/或徒步旅行，然后我用壶铃做一些训练。比较轻松的东西。
You got a trainer? You're doing this on your own? No, I do it on my own. I'm pretty consistent. That's cool. Yeah. And so that's been good. He taught me this really cool thing, which is he's like 40 minutes before you go to bed, before you're going to go to sleep, eat like a cup of berries or a sorbet.
你有教练吗？还是你自己一个人练？不，我自己练。我相当有恒心。那挺酷的。是的。所以这很不错。他教了我一个非常酷的方法，就是他告诉我：在你睡觉前40分钟，在你准备入睡之前，吃一杯浆果或者雪芭。
And he gave me a couple brands so that you get that spike of natural sugar. And then you'll crash. and you'll have a, you'll go into a sleep better and you'll sleep better. And he, God damn it, he was right. Oh, and there's probably the psychological element of like, now I get to have my treat. You get a little treat. And then it's like, and a little treat and then you're going to bed and like, oh, that's a real interesting wind down. Pretty insane. Pretty insane.
他还给我推荐了几个品牌，这样你能获得天然糖分的峰值。然后你的血糖会下降，
My version of that is I switch from a joint and a bourbon to a joint and a camomile tea. Oh, that's nice. And that has been, and I'm out on my balcony, sipping tea and having an indica. And I'm like, I'm going to sleep like a baby. It's so much better for me than two, two fingers are fucking, uh, basil Hayden's. Two fingers. Much like, much like my only fans, I prefer a little more than two fingers. Well, I mean, alcohol is the big, alcohol is the big thing that like, uh, I mean. It's a saboteur of your health.
你会进入更好的睡眠状态，睡得更好。而他，妈的，他说得对。哦，这可能还有一个心理层面的因素，就像：现在我终于可以吃点好吃的了。你得到了一个小奖励。然后这就变成：吃个小奖励，然后你就要去睡觉了，然后心想：哦，这真是一个非常有趣的放松方式。太疯狂了。太疯狂了。
Yeah. It's like you let it in. A1 killer. Yeah. It's, it's trash. And it's for a lot of different reasons. And yeah, I'm, I don't drink. I'm so happy that I don't.
我的版本是：我把一根大麻卷加波旁威士忌换成了一根大麻卷加洋甘菊茶。哦，那挺不错的。而且那种感觉……我坐在阳台上，啜吸着茶，抽着籼稻大麻（indica）。然后我想：我今晚要睡得像个婴儿一样。这比喝两手指宽的……该死的巴塞尔·海登（Basil Hayden's）威士忌要好得多。两手指宽。就像……就像我的 OnlyFans 一样，我更喜欢稍微多于两指的东西。好吧，我是说，酒精是个大问题，酒精是个巨大的……我是说，
for myriad reasons. But one of them is, you know, every time there's a new study that comes out, which is like every four hours. Every four hours, Huberman's making a fucking proclamation about, I can't believe we ever drank alcohol. You're like, oh, come on, man. And I just think, oh, thank God I don't.
它是你健康的破坏者。是的。就像你放任它侵蚀。头号杀手。是的。它就是垃圾。出于很多不同的原因。而且，是的，我不喝酒。我太高兴我不喝了。
And I do, I do feel better as a result of it. And you can't do it as you get older, too. Like, you just can't, like your body can't do it. It's harder. It takes more and more of its toll on you every year. I want to quit smoking butts. I really do. And I don't smoke as much as I used to.
出于种种原因。但其中之一就是，你知道，每当有新的研究出来时——大概每四小时就有一个。每四小时，休伯曼（Huberman）就会发表一个该死的声明，说：我真不敢相信我们以前喝过酒。你会想：哦，得了吧，老兄。我只想：哦，谢天谢地我不喝。
Are you zinning? Yeah. I mean, I just put one out. I just stubbed one out. That's the level. I have a problem to zinn. I can't do it. So many of my friends are zinning.
而且我确实……因此我感觉好多了。随着年龄增长，你也确实不能喝了。就像你根本不能……你的身体承受不消了。这更难了。它每年对你身体造成的摧残越来越重。我想戒烟。我是认真的。而且我抽得没有以前多了。
So many of my friends are zinning and still blasting Sigs, which is like, I'm like. Yeah, it's me. I don't do it at the same time. At the same time. I've got people who are telling me that nicotine is actually like a neutral. and it's like it's like a performance and answer it is we actually just had hubbard man on on the podcast and i gotta say he was pretty great and i ended up being fascinated with everything he was saying and i didn't want it to end and i was like and what if i do this and what if i like i was like the little kid you know yeah and he talked about nicotine and how great it is yeah i just look like i have nine zins in my mouth at all time yeah wills hit in the five milly uh what do they call them the uh uh five-mill lip pillow or whatever. I'm on the three right now,
你在用 Zyn（无烟尼古丁袋）吗？对。我是说，我刚掐灭一根。这就是我的水平。我对 Zyn 上瘾了。我戒不掉。我好多朋友都在用 Zyn。
but I go back and forth between the three and the sixes. And then what does it do? It's just like a pouch, like a baseball player, or is it like, or is it like, or like, no,
我好多朋友都在用 Zyn，而且还在疯狂抽烟，这让我觉得……是的，就是我。我不会同时进行。不会同时进行。有些人告诉我尼古丁其实是中性的，它就像是一种表现增强剂。确实如此。我们刚刚把休伯曼请到了播客上，我得说他真的很棒，我最终对他说的一切都着迷了，我根本不想让访谈结束，我当时想：如果我这样做会怎样？如果我那样做会怎样？我就像个小孩子一样，你知道的。
you just put it, he's put it between your lip and your teeth. It takes a second to get used to. It's like these little pouches like this. And I know for a fact, based on our experience, that Adam can't handle just packing a lip with something. We did recreational ketamine together
然后他谈到了尼古丁以及它有多棒。是的，我看起来就像嘴里随时塞了九个 Zyn。是的，威尔在用 5 毫克的……他们叫它什么来着？5 毫克的唇部枕头还是什么的。我目前在用 3 毫克的，
and you're supposed to just put it in your, lip and Adam's like, I chewed it and swallowed it. I was like, what the fuck? You can't leave it there. It's like a little kid. I played a baseball in high school. I've been like, swallowing sunflowers.
但我会在 3 毫克和 6 毫克之间换着用。那这东西到底是怎么用的？它就像是一个小包，像棒球运动员用的那样，还是像……还是像什么……不，
As soon as that shit started, like, as soon as you go from sunflower seeds to like the first kid brings in chewing tobacco, I was just like, like, I can't, I can't pack a lip in high school. I can't do it. I have a weird, that's funny you saying that I have a weird time off, half the time when I would go to get it out of my lip, I start the gag. I don't know why. that that place. It's also, I can't, I also gag when I put my contact lenses.
你把它放在嘴唇和牙齿之间。需要花一会儿时间适应。它就像这样的小药包。而且我根据经验确切地知道，亚当根本没办法把嘴唇塞满某种东西进行尝试。我们曾经一起嗑过娱乐性氯胺酮（ketamine），
Well, I think you're supposed to put him in your eyes. Not at the back of your throat. I thought you swam. I have no gag reflex. Again, I'm sorry. That's for my only fans. Clip that. Clip that for my only fans. Fuck, that's a great clip on its own. That's going to be the clip. That, I mean, I get somehow gets credited to Will, unfortunately. It's like Will Arnette's got no. Will Arnette says tattoos. Tattoes are bad. Again. Never live it down. It does make you think about Tom Hanks.
本该把它放在嘴唇里的，而亚当却说：我把它嚼了然后咽下去了。我当时想：他妈的什么鬼？你不能把它留在那儿。就像个小孩子。我高中时打过棒球。我一直在……就像吞葵花籽一样。
God, he's done so many different things. The dude's kind of unreal. I was just thinking about his run the other day. It's unreal. Right? His run from like Joe versus the volcano maybe. He splashes the original. He made a few clunkers.
一旦那玩意儿开始……就像你从葵花籽换成第一个带嚼烟去学校的小孩时，我就在想：我高中时可没法在嘴唇里塞一包嚼烟。我做不到。我有一种奇怪的……你这么说真搞笑，我有一半时间想把它从嘴唇里拿出来时，我都开始反胃了。我不知道为什么，那个地方……还有，我把隐形眼镜放进眼里时也会反胃。
I mean, they didn't, they never stuck. They never stuck to him. Yeah, like a clunker for time. Yeah, yeah, but he made like 60 movies and he made like 30 really good movies. So like half of them. I'm going to let him have. I mean, mine is I made only clunkers. Dude, I was to say like, do you know, if you looked at my IMDP, like my average, I'm batting 164 in the miners.
好吧，我想你是应该把它戴进眼睛里。而不是塞到喉咙后边。我还以为你会游泳呢。我没有呕吐反射。再次说明，抱歉。那是为了我的 OnlyFans 准备的。把这个剪下来。把这个为我的 OnlyFans 剪下来。操，这绝对是一个极佳的单剪片段。这会成为爆款片段。这个……我的意思是，不知怎么的，这会被归功于威尔，不幸的是。就像威尔·阿奈特说……威尔·阿奈特说纹身。纹身不好。又来了。永远摆脱不了这个梗了。这确实让你想起汤姆·汉克斯。
Hank's also did like 10 years of dominating comedy and then switch to drama and then was the go-to drama guy for like another decade. Similar to you, Will. You're a little late, but a little late. I don't think I'm, brother Solomon. I don't think I'm dominating anything. I don't know, dude. I think it depends on how you look at it.
天哪，他演过那么多完全不同的角色。这家伙简直不是凡人。我前几天还在想他演艺生涯的高峰期。太不可思议了。对吧？他从《魔幻屠夫》（Joe Versus the Volcano）开始的高峰期。他演过《美人鱼》（Splash）原版。他也拍过一些烂片。
Like, this is your turn to Hank's run it. Just a couple years later than he did. We're just doing a few more terminals. I decided to wait until I was 55 Because I didn't want to embarrass anybody I love it when people People do say to me sometimes they're like Do you ever think about doing like a drama
我是说，那些烂片没有……它们从来没粘在他身上。是的，烂片对时代而言……是的，是的，但他拍了大概60部电影，其中有30部是非常好的电影。所以有一半……我挺佩服他的。我是说，我的情况是……我只拍烂片。老兄，我想说的是，如果你看看我的 IMDb，我的平均水准，我在小联盟里的打击率是 164。
Like changing up and always like Yeah Yeah Yeah I'm trying to do comedy I'm like it all the time Yeah What you got?
汉克斯还做了大概10年的喜剧统治者，然后转型去演剧情片，接着又在另一个十年里成为首选的剧情片男演员。跟你很像，威尔。你稍微晚了一点，不过也就晚了一点。我不觉得自己……所罗门兄弟（Brother Solomon）。我不觉得自己统治了什么。不知道，老兄。我觉得这取决于你怎么看。
Yeah You're like you know what you got to do You got to work with really good directors Yeah okay Yeah great I'm available. I would love that. Have you showed them my extensive
就像，这是你迎来汉克斯式高峰的时刻。只是比他晚了几年。我们只是多拍了几部《幸福终点站》（The Terminal）。我决定等到55岁才开始，因为我不想让任何人感到尴尬。我真的很喜欢当别人有时候对我说：你有没有想过演点剧情片？
20 year television career? Yeah. Because you could Google me. You got a number on them? Let me just, you got a number on them? It's like, oh, it'd be so cool if you worked with Wes Anderson.
就像换个风格，然后我总是说：对，对，对。我一直在努力演喜剧。我无时无刻不在演。你有什么？
You're like, fuck yeah, I would. Yeah. It would be fucking awesome. That's like, that's the real like grown up version of your aunt saying like, you should do the Conan O'Brien show. You should do what he does. You know, and you're like, yeah, I would love to.
对。你就像是：你知道你得做什么吗？你得和非常优秀的导演合作。对，好吧。太好了，我很 verfügbar（可用）。我很乐意。你给他们看我长达20年的电视演艺生涯了吗？
Right. I should. I should get on SNL at 44. I could speed run my fucking speedball death. I was going to ask you by this press run that you've been doing because it's a dream of mine as someone who's worked, you know, in comedy the way you have for a long time to see you doing the like a academy, a, like, academy. War run press tour where you're like in cool clothes and like you know what I mean? And there's like pictures of you
是的。因为你可以谷歌搜索我。你手里有他们的电话吗？让我……你手里有他们的电话吗？就像：哦，如果你能和韦斯·安德森（Wes Anderson）合作该多酷啊。
in a swimming pool with clothes on. You know and there's like sitting sitting cross-legged in like the W lobby with like with a bourbon or something. And then there's like an interview with you and Odessa Zion together. You're like you're doing
你会想：操，废话，我当然想！那太他妈棒了。那就好比是你姑妈说的成年人版：“你应该去上柯南·奥布莱恩（Conan O’Brien）的节目。你应该去做他做的事。”你知道的，然后你会想：对，我很乐意。
it. You know like how does that feel? Like do you ever? Does the comedian part of you ever, because I consider you like a comedian, you are one of the, you're comedian. Like, do you, does that side of your brain ever click on while you're doing, while you're doing it all while you're like, wow, this is new? A gazillion percent. And so what the difference is, well, yeah, I, I spent a lot, long time, you know, doing stuff and fucking around. And what happens is by the end, like when you do something with, as part of that, when you go and you do something like with Ramesh and I'm just dicking around, it's so fun because then I just get to dick around, which is why I say a bunch of stupid shit that I don't mean. Because you're just, you're just having fun, right?
对。我应该在44岁时去上《周六夜现场》（SNL）。我可以直接加速我那场该死的速球式死亡。我本来想问你关于你一直在跑的这一轮宣传活动，因为作为一个在喜剧界工作了很久、像你一样的人，我的梦想之一就是看到你去做那种……学院奖风格的宣传巡演，那种你穿着很酷的衣服……你知道我的意思吗？照片里还有你
But a lot of those things, you got to go. And, you know, look, the movie we made, this, this movie is this thing on that Bradley and Mark Chavlin and I wrote. And we worked on for, it took like from the time that we decided to start doing it until the time. that it came out was like seven and a half years or something, right? Jesus. Yeah. And so, so like we took it really seriously and we did it and it's a and we spent a lot of time on it obviously and a lot of care and so you come out with it and then when they start to you know starts thinking like hey maybe this has a chance for people to recognize it for X, Y and Z you want to give it the you're
穿着衣服坐在游泳池里。你知道的，还有那种盘腿坐在 W 酒店大堂里，手里拿着一杯波旁威士忌什么的。然后还有你和敖德萨·赛恩（Odessa Young）一起接受采访。你就像是在……你在亲历这一切。
you're doing a bunch of different stuff and so you're you want to speak very it's tough because you don't want for me I feel like man it's hard for me to be that earnest in a way yeah yeah that's what I mean comedy is not comedy is inherently like you want to undercut yourself and undercut the situation so frequently yeah yeah but then you but it but you know what the same rules apply in that you just got to read the room which is these are people here who are appreciating it and so that you you do take it seriously and I did take seriously doing the the project itself and I do really like it and I am really proud of it. So then, but there were times where, yeah, where you just kind of like, you, you, you,
你知道，这感觉怎么样？你有没有……你内心喜剧演员的那一部分，因为我视你为一个喜剧演员，你就是其中之一，你是个喜剧演员。你大脑里的那一面，当你在经历这一切、当你意识到“哇，这太新鲜了”的时候，它会突然被激活吗？十亿个百分点。所以不同之处在于，好吧，是的，我花了很长时间，你知道的，一直在搞七捻三、胡闹。而结果就是，到了最后，当你参与某些活动时——作为其中的一部分，当你和拉梅什一起做节目，我只是在胡闹，这太有趣了，因为那样我就可以尽情胡闹，这就是为什么我会说一堆我根本没当真的蠢话。因为你只是在玩乐，对吧？
you fuck around. But, but a lot of the time, you know, the questions are different too. The questions are like what, you know, why did you do this? Or what is the message or, you know, what was the process like? And you're like, well, actually, the process was pretty serious. Yeah, it took a lot of preparation. Yeah, to do those scenes. It took a lot of, we workshop for a long time.
但其中很多事情，你必须去……而且，听着，我们拍的这部电影，这部电影《这个正在发生》（This Thing On），是布莱德利、马克·查夫林（Mark Chappell）和我一起写的。我们为之付出了努力，从我们决定开始做这件事到它上映，花了大约七年半的时间，对吧？天哪。
And you find yourself down this road. and I did have a few times that there were some really cool interviewers who were like, I see that you're struggling with talking about it in this serious way. Well, there's like the, there's another layer to it too that you're a comedy guy doing serious interviews about a serious movie about comedy. It's like a quadruple 4D cake or some shit. Yeah, man.
是的。所以我们非常认真地对待它，我们完成了它，这是一个……我们显然在上面花了大量的时间和心血，所以当你推出它时，当他们开始……你知道的，开始觉得：嘿，也许这有机会让大家从 X、Y、Z 的角度去认可它，你想给它……
That's a thing. Yeah, it's complicated. And, and, uh, and then, But at the same time, and then what happens is it's very alluring because people do respond to it. And they're like, hey, we really liked it. And we thought it was a great story. And you're like, you're kind of forced to put your guard down. It was tough for me to kind of talk about me and or it in this way that didn't feel like,
你正在做很多不同的事情，所以你想说得非常……这很难，因为你不想……对我来说，我觉得：天哪，要我那么一本正经地说话真的好难。是的，是的，这就是我的意思：喜剧不是……喜剧本质上就是让你经常忍不住贬低自己、贬低当时的情况。是的，是的。但随后你……但你知道，这里面的道理是一样的，你只需要审时度势，也就是说，这里的人们是来欣赏它的，所以你要认真对待它，我也确实认真对待了项目本身，而且我真的很喜欢它，我也为之感到骄傲。所以，但也有一些时候，是的，你只是……你、你、你……
I kept trying to, I was like catching myself. I didn't want to seem like I was being self-aggrandizing. Do you know what I mean? This is the most understandable, like, headspace to be. My therapist one time said to me, do you ever use positive self-talk with yourself? I was like, no, why? That would be corny. He's like, no, that is something you need to like.
你在胡闹。但是，很多时候，你知道，问题也是不同的。问题就像是：你知道的，你为什么要做这个？或者说传达的信息是什么？或者，你知道，创作过程是怎样的？你会觉得：嗯，其实，这个过程相当严肃。是的，这需要大量的准备。是的，为了拍好那些场景。这花了很多精力，我们排练了很长时间。
And I'm like, oh, fuck, I never, like, it's so easy to just downplay everything. But then when you're a part of something larger, like a piece of art that you're involved with other creatives that you're like, I can't go out here and downplay this because I worked hard. Other people worked hard. My instinct is to like undercut myself for the sake of comedy and to not come across as, like a guy who is too serious. What made it easy was, in certain ways, was that the people I worked with, you know, A, Bradley, you know,
然后你会发现自己走上了这条路。我确实有几次遇到了一些非常酷的采访者，他们会说：我看得出来，你很不习惯用这种严肃的方式谈论它。好吧，这里还有另一层意思，那就是你是一个喜剧演员，正在就一部关于喜剧的严肃电影接受严肃的采访。这就像是一个四维的超级蛋糕什么的。是的，老兄。
he's... I got a billion questions. Yeah, he's an incredible... He's an incredible filmmaker, right? I mean, and I've known him a long time. His capacity for all of it is so insane. And his concentration and his focus
就是这样。是的，这很复杂。而且，而且，与此同时，接下来发生的事情是，它非常有吸引力，因为人们确实对此有反应。他们会说：嘿，我们真的很喜欢它。我们觉得这是一个很棒的故事。然后你会觉得……你有点被迫放下防备。对我来说，要以这种不像是……的方式谈论我和这部电影，真的很艰难。
is so intense in the best way. And Laura Dern, who's one of our greats, You know, and she's just, she's just incredible. And so you kind of, you, you start to get in that, you know, I heard, but what's, what's interesting is, so, so that part of it made it really easy. And then when you listen to that and the way they talk about you're like, okay, yeah, I can talk about this thing. And, and I did take it seriously. You know, what's weird is, you know, as Pally, you were saying that, like, you go and you're doing these, like, screenings for the academy and stuff.
我一直在试图……我一直在提醒自己。我不想显得自己是在自我标榜。你知道我的意思吗？这是最可以理解的心态了。我的治疗师曾经对我说过：你有没有对自己进行过积极的自我对话？我说：没有，为什么？那多老土啊。他说：不，那是你需要去……
And, of course, we didn't get any nominations for anything for our film. Not about that. I know, but what's weird is they, you get put in this place where you've got to go and do that. And then, and then you're disappointed. And then you're like, I heard Ben Affleck talking about it. I think on Kimmel maybe or something recently, and he was much more articulate than I was. But about this idea that people are like, oh, man, sorry, didn't get the thing. And you're like, I didn't even, when we made it, it's not like I was thinking like, wow, we're going to get, we're going to make this Academy Award winning thing.
然后我想：哦，操，我从来没有……你知道，贬低一切太容易了。但当你参与到更宏大的事物中时——比如你与其他创意人员共同参与的一件艺术品，你会想：我不能跑出来贬低这个，因为我付出了努力。其他人也付出了努力。我的本能是为了喜剧效果而贬低自己，以免显得自己是个太严肃的人。
thing. When you get drafted in the NFL, you're not like, fuck. I just want to get, if I don't win the Super Bowl, I just want to get out of the field. And that was it. We just wanted to make something good. So played a great game. So it's confusing. And I remember my 15 year old said to me, and he's such a great kid and you want to talk about this kid is so funny. He's an absolute bit machine. It's unreal. It's unreal. It's in the jeans.
在某些方面，让事情变得容易的原因是，我合作的人们，你知道的，A，布莱德利，你知道的，
Do not introduce him to my son. I do not. I don't need two of that. My son is a nightmare. Yeah, bit machine, right? Yeah, it's insane. And we were driving home and I was driving him home somewhere. I was out here in California and I said that and we found out like that we something came out. We didn't get, we didn't get recognized. And he goes, and I hung up and I go, yeah, he goes, what happened?
他……我有无数个问题。是的，他是一个不可思议的……他是一个不可思议的电影人，对吧？我是说，我认识他很久了。他处理这一切的能力太疯狂了。他的注意力和专注力
I go, yeah, it's a bit of a bummer. And he goes, don't let the fact that that happened ruin what you think about this great movie that you made, Dad. and I was like, you're right. You're absolutely right. It was so dope. It was so dope. And like it took my 15 year old to give me the perspective.
以最好的方式达到了极高的强度。还有劳拉·邓恩（Laura Dern），我们最伟大的演员之一，你知道的，她简直……她简直不可思议。所以你开始融入那种……你知道的，我听过……但有趣的是，所以，那一部分让事情变得非常容易。然后当你听着那些以及他们谈论你的方式时，你会想：好吧，是的，我可以谈论这件事。而且，我确实认真对待了。
Yeah, the clarity comes from the most of the wildest places sometimes. You worked with our mutual friend. Oh, real quick. My buddy Bob Castrone. Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Dude, Bobby Castro is one of the all-time funny dudes.
你知道奇怪的是什么吗，帕利，就像你刚才说的，你去了，你在为学院奖之类的事情做这些放映活动。当然，我们的电影没有任何一项获得提名。不是指那个。我知道，但奇怪的是，你被置于那种必须去跑这些活动的境地。然后，然后你感到了失望。然后你会想：我听到本·阿弗莱克（Ben Affleck）最近在谈论这个，可能是在吉米·坎摩尔（Kimmel）的节目上或者别的什么地方，他比我表达得更清晰。但关于这种想法：人们会说：哦，天哪，真遗憾，没拿到那个奖。而你会想：甚至在我们制作它的时候，我也不是在想：哇，我们要拍一部赢得奥斯卡奖的东西。
Yeah, one of the best. I met him when I was a PA at Best Week. ever like 20 something years ago when I graduated college and we've been tight ever since. I mean, you want to talk about Bit Machine. Bob Castro. So Bob came with us when we were doing, because as you know, he used to be a stand-up back in the day. Yeah.
当你被 NFL 选中时，你不会想：操。我只想……如果我赢不了超级碗，我只想上场踢球。就是这样。我们只是想拍一部好东西。所以踢了一场精彩的比赛。所以这让人困惑。我记得我15岁的儿子对我说过——他是个多么棒的孩子啊，你想聊聊的话，这孩子太搞笑了。他简直就是个“梗制造机”。这太不可思议了。这太不可思议了。这基因里带的。
And so when I started doing stand-up and was going to the cellar when I was living- Were you using your name? Were you using, like, would they say, ladies and gentlemen, Will Arnett? No, no, no. I was using the name of the character, which was, yeah. Some fucking I know Well I was doing it
所以当我开始说脱口秀，去Cellar酒吧的时候，我当时住—你用的是你自己的名字吗？你用的是，比如说，他们会说，女士们先生们，威尔·阿奈特吗？不，不，不。我用的是角色的名字，就是那样。真他妈的，我知道，好吧，我当时在做这个
Yeah I think that people were like Is he doing like Some like low rent Andy Kaufman ripoff Daniel Day Lewis over here Daniel Dave Lewis doing On the set
对，我想当时人们会觉得，他在搞什么鬼？像是什么低端版的安迪·考夫曼山寨货？还是这边的丹尼尔·戴-刘易斯？丹尼尔·戴-刘易斯在片场呢
Everyone call me Will I'm living the life All right Everyone treat me like Will Okay I stand up comic He's going through a divorce All right
大家都叫我威尔，我过着这样的人生，好吧。大家都把我当威尔看待，好吧。我是一个单口喜剧演员，他正在经历离婚，好吧
So I So I would go down. And so Bob, Bob came with me in, because we wrote all the stand-up, you know, that's in the film that kind of tracks where this character of Alex is going and stuff. And so I wanted to have that experience, truly what it was like to be this dude. And I'm not a stand-up, so I'd never done it before. But I wanted to understand what that experience was going down and being that dude. And so really what I got to do is kind of rehearse for six weeks and going to the comedy cellar every night and walking down, stairs and being introduced as Alex Novak and people did like kind of
所以我，所以我就会去。然后鲍勃，鲍勃跟我一起去了，因为我们写了所有的单口喜剧内容，你知道的，就是电影里的那些，大致记录了这个叫亚历克斯的角色要去哪里之类的内容。所以我想有那种经历，真正去体会当这个家伙是什么感觉。我又不是一个单口喜剧演员，所以我以前从没做过。但我想理解那种走下去并成为那个家伙的体验。所以实际上我得到的是彩排了六周，每天晚上去喜剧Cellar酒吧，走下楼梯，被介绍为亚历克斯·诺瓦克，然后人们就会有一种
I'd get up there that sort of snicker and think like I was losing my mind or whatever and but then poor will he's going going through it I mean sorry Alex I joke I did joke though I did joke that people are you know like a you know so I'm getting divorced and stuff that people are Googling like this asshole got married again like what and you were doing a super high-pitched voice right No gravel. I was doing like this. Dude,
我上去的时候那种窃笑，觉得我疯了什么的，但是接着，可怜的威尔，他正在经历这一切，我是说，对不起，亚历克斯，我开玩笑的，我确实开玩笑说人们，你知道的，就像，你知道的，所以我正在离婚什么的，人们在谷歌上搜索，比如这个混蛋又结婚了，怎么回事，而且你当时在用一种超级尖的嗓音对吧？没有，很沙哑。我当时是这样。老兄，
the worst part of that was lugging that prop bin up and down those stairs though, right? I'm glad you guys did the rewrite to make Alex not a prop comic.
那里面最糟糕的部分是把那个道具箱搬上搬下楼梯，对吧？我很高兴你们重写了剧本，让亚历克斯不是一个道具喜剧演员。
I think those a smart movie. It was so, it was such a, I'm glad we dropped that because it was, it was just hard to get the shit
我觉得那是一部聪明的电影。这真是，这真是，我很高兴我们放弃了那个，因为，把那些破东西搬上搬下楼梯实在太难了
up and down the stairs. It was so. The art department was furious that was so happy. I made everything, the plunger, the chicken,
太难了。美术部门气死了，不过（我）太高兴了。我弄了所有东西，柱塞，鸡，
the glass, all of them. And you've got to be careful with it. You can't just throw it down. You have to place it. No, well, there's an anvil in there. You can't throw it down. It's going to ruin the chicken.
杯子，全都有。而且你得小心对待它。你不能就这么把它扔下来。你得把它摆好。不，好吧，里面有个铁砧。你不能把它扔下来。会把那只鸡弄坏的。
We come from improv, as you know. And so, like, there is, that is a different thing. Like, we, you know, we, we, we, we, we, we, we, we, we, we, we, we, we, we, we, we, we, we, we, we, we, we, we, we, we, we, we, we, we, we, we, we, we, we, we, we, we, we, we, we, we, we, So much stage time, but no crossover. Where you're like, oh, I can get on stage. You're like, I can get on stage with no material in front of however many people and feel, feel comfortable. And then you're like, but that doesn't mean anything. That's not currency.
我们出身于即兴表演，如你所知。所以，就像，那是另一回事。比如，我们，你知道的，我们，我们，我们，有那么多的舞台时间，但没有交叉点。就好像，哦，我可以上台。你会觉得，我可以在不管多少人面前不上任何素材就上台，并且感到，感到自在。然后你会想，但这并不意味着什么。那不是硬通货。
That's not, you know, it's not music. It's like shitty jazz, you know, in a way. It's like, well, what, you know, what was interesting was so, so when I was, yeah, so when I'd go down there, the first time that I did it at the cellar, we walked down the stairs and I was there with Bob Castrone and in Bradley and we're standing there by the doorway, you know, downstairs there at the main room there. And I'm about to, they're about to call me up. And Bradley knows me and he knows that. I'm going to, if I get up there, that because I didn't come up through improv, I wish I had, I wish I'd known about it, I wish it existed in that way when I was coming up. adjacent. I mean, you, I'm adjacent. We've hung out at McManus enough for you to be considered
那不是，你知道的，那不是音乐。在某种程度上，这就像糟糕的爵士乐。就好像，有趣的是，所以，所以当我，是的，所以当我走下去的时候，我在Cellar酒吧第一次表演时，我们走下楼梯，我跟鲍勃·卡斯特罗还有布拉德利在一起，我们站在门口旁边，你知道，楼下那个主房间那里。我正要被，他们正要叫我上台。布拉德利了解我，他知道，如果我上台，因为我不是通过即兴表演出身的——我希望我是，我希望我当时就知道它，我希望当我刚出道时它能以那种方式存在。沾边。我是说，你，我是沾边的。我们在McManus酒吧鬼混得够多了，足以让你被认为
an improviser. Yes, but, but like I wish, I just wish that that was kind of around more when I was, when I first moved to New York in 1990. Yeah. It just was it. So, but, but I, but he knows that my instinct is that if I get up, if I walk down there, get on stage, that I'll try to figure out a way to make, to squeeze out a laugh somehow. To make it work. To make it work. To do something and whatever. And the first time he stopped me and he puts his hand on me and he, he leans in and he goes,
是一个即兴演员。是的，但是，但是就像我希望，我只是希望当我1990年初刚搬到纽约时，那种东西能更多一点。是的。它就是没有。所以，但是，但是我知道，但他知道我的直觉是，如果我上台，如果我走下去，上台，我会试图想出一个办法，无论如何都要挤出一个笑声来。让它行得通。让它行得通。做点什么之类的。而第一次他阻止了我，他把手搭在我身上，他，他凑过来，然后他说，
we're doing something different. And basically we're saying, you're not doing that. We're here to do this. This is the job. And so go out there and do the material as Alex and do Alex's material that we do from the film, which is what I did. And that was really dope. Yeah, because the impulse would be to be,
我们在做一些不同的事情。基本上我们是在说，你不是在做那个。我们来这里是为了做这个。这就是工作。所以走出去，作为亚历克斯来表演素材，表演我们从电影里拿来的亚历克斯的素材，而我就是这么做的。这真的很酷。是的，因为冲动会是，
like, I know how to impress this crowd. I'm a funny guy. Give me a mic. Yeah, just lean on my sweaty bits. You know what I mean? Yeah, the tattoo thing. Let me try something out of here, guys. From everything you said, the, the, I mean, I've had a director that I've really loved working
就像，我知道怎么给这群观众留下深刻印象。我是个搞笑的人。给我个麦克风。是的，就靠着我那些出汗的桥段。你知道我的意思吗？对，文身那事。让我从这里挑点东西试试，伙计们。从你所说的一切来看，我，我意思是，我遇到过一个真正喜欢合作、我信任的导演
with that I trust, you know what I mean? But I never had a, like, a friend who is also my director who's like, it must have been really bonding where you're doing this. If you guys were like going undercover. writing the movie as it as it's forming, you know what I mean? Like that's pretty special to have a friend that's like, hey, man, don't do your bullshit tonight. And then, but trust, but trust me that I'm going to have your back and make you look good.
你知道我的意思吗？但我从来没有过这样一个朋友，他同时也是我的导演，那种感觉就像，你们做这事的时候一定很有凝聚力。如果你们当时就像在当卧底，边构思边写剧本，你知道我的意思吗？有一个朋友对你说“嘿，兄弟，今晚别搞你那一套破玩意儿了”，这感觉挺特别的。然后，但相信，相信我会支持你，让你看起来很棒。
100%. And it was, and it was, you know, again, because I do, I got to see sort of under the hood over the last couple of years as we were working on developing it. What an incredible mind he has for this kind of thing and for making movies. So I trusted that in that moment and it did help us be you're absolutely right I'm in terms of Weeks later when we actually start shooting I do that trust is just built built built built and such a strong thing and then and then Actually was you know coming to those moments where we had these really insanely vulnerable moments in the film and I've got to trust him and he's you know I'm be I I've never done anything like
百分之百。而且，而且，你知道的，再次重申，因为我确实，在过去几年我们开发它的过程中，得以一窥内幕。他对这种事情以及拍电影有着多么不可思议的才华。所以我相信了那一刻，它确实帮了我们——你绝对没说错——几周后当我们真正开始拍摄时，这种信任就在不断地建立，建立，建立，建立，变成了一件如此强大的事情，然后，然后实际上，你知道的，迎来了那些我们在电影中拥有这些极其脆弱的时刻，我必须信任他，而他，你知道的，我是——我从未在电影中以这种方式做过
like this on film in this way. And I had to kind of, you know, we talked about it. And he'd be like, you gotta trust me that you have to, there's, there can be no bullshit here. There's no acting, there's no bullshit. You have to, and we gotta go deep. And he would like pull the camera off. He's operating too.
像这样的事情。我不得不，你知道的，我们谈过。他会说，你必须相信我，你必须这样做，这里不能有任何废话。没有表演，没有废话。你必须，我们必须深入挖掘。他甚至会把摄像机拿开。他自己也在操作机器。
So that was the crazy- Soderberg style. It's like, yeah. He and- Well, that's also, where's he gonna sit? There's no freaking chairs. There's no chairs. By the way, there's no chairs,
所以这就是疯狂的索德伯格风格。就像是，没错。他和——好吧，这也是，他要坐在哪？根本没有该死的椅子。没有椅子。顺便说一句，根本没有椅子，
there's no video village, right? Yeah. Everything's intense. From the moment you should, show up from call time to rap. There's never a break. There's never sitting around. I wish for that.
没有摄像监视村，对吧？是的。一切都非常紧张。从你该到的那一刻起，从集合时间到收工。从来没有休息。从来没有闲坐着。我真希望有。
It's amazing. So you're always engaged and he's right there. He's a foot from me with the camera in my face. And he's talking to me as we're rolling. And he's like, here we go. Here we go, man. Here we go. And then you go like, we got to go.
太棒了。所以你总是全神贯注，他就站在那。离我只有一英尺，相机就对着我的脸。我们在实拍时他就在跟我说话。他会说，我们开始吧。我们走，老兄。我们走。然后你会想，我们要上了。
We've got to go deep on this. We got to go. You got to fucking throw it all the way. All this kind of shit. It was dope, man. It was scary as fuck. That is amazing. Can you introduce us to Bradley?
我们得深入探讨这个。我们得上了。你得他妈的全力以赴。诸如此类的一堆破事。太酷了，老兄。吓死我了。太棒了。你能把我们介绍给布拉德利吗？
I know. I'm not ready to hang out with Bradley yet. I need a couple more years. I'm not concerned that he's ready to make a movie. You guys should work with Bradley. I didn't say movie. I don't want to hang out. I'm not ready to hang out with Bradley yet.
我知道。我还没准备好和布拉德利一起混。我还得再过几年。我不担心他是否准备好拍电影。你们应该和布拉德利合作。我没说电影。我不想闲逛。我还没准备好和布拉德利一起混。
I need a couple more years. Because there are people like that in my life who like, I feel like I'm going to meet Bradley Cooper and I'm going to be like, I got to get more like Bradley Cooper. And you know what I mean? And like right now, right now I just got to. I can't handle that identity. I can't handle that.
我还需要几年时间。因为我生命中有些那样的人，我觉得我要去见布拉德利·库珀了，然后我会想，我得变得更像布拉德利·库珀。你知道我的意思吗？就像现在，现在我必须这样做。我无法承受那种身份。我无法承受。
I can't handle that right now. I got to just figure out me. He's crazy inspiring. I mean, again, like, it, it, our whole thing, our whole relationship went into a totally different gear. And he really inspired me in, in so many ways. It was pretty sick. Are you going to do it again?
我现在承受不了这个。我得先搞清楚我自己。他简直太鼓舞人心了。我的意思是，话说回来，我们的整件事情，我们的整个关系进入了一个完全不同的档次。他在方方面面都真的激励了我。这真是太酷了。你还会再演吗？
Are you going to, I mean, are you going to, obviously the material, you're, you're getting a different look now, right? Like, there's got to be cooler stuff. Yeah. Or a more, more variety of. things in front of you that you can do next. Yeah, for sure. That's the exciting.
你会，我是说，你会，显然是剧本，你现在有了不同的视角，对吧？就像，一定有更酷的东西。或者在你面前有更多、更多样化的事情你可以接下来做。是的，肯定的。这就是让人兴奋的。
That's the exciting part. And I'm not, what's funny is, again, I think because maybe I'm, because I'm 55, I'm not, I'm not, I'm not precious about it. I'm not like, hey, now this is what I do. But I had these, like, really sort of very, what should be obvious realizations. But it's taken me a long time where I go, like, I only want to do stuff. that I that I respond to.
这就是令人兴奋的部分。而且我，有趣的是，话说回来，我想也许是因为我，因为我55岁了，我对它并不，并不，并不太看重。我不是那种，嘿，现在这就是我的工作的人。但我有了这些，真的非常，应该显而易见的感悟。但这花了我很长时间，让我觉得，我只想做那些。
Wow. I haven't had that revelation. I was like, what? And they're like, yeah, what I did. And so,
哇。我可没有这种顿悟。我就像，什么？他们说，对，我做过的事。所以，
so it's been cool. Yeah. And it has been different. You know, I just finished this thing, um, um, um,
所以这很酷。是的。而且确实不同。你知道，我刚拍完这部作品，嗯，嗯，嗯，
with Tony Gilroy, which is pretty dope. Oh. Yeah. Whoa. Yeah. And with with Pedro Pascal and that was, that was really awesome and Olivia Wilde in a bunch.
和托尼·吉尔罗伊合作，这真的很酷。哦。是的。哇。是的，还有佩德罗·帕斯卡，那真是太棒了，还有奥利维亚·王尔德以及其他人。
It was pretty dope. And, and so just a small little thing, but, but like, really cool to be able to kind of do do some different stuff so that's uh yeah i'm pretty i'm pretty psyched about it are you are you looking to downshift and to do a comedy again and be like oh fucking like safety i feel like a lot like you know what i mean like you're like okay like yeah yeah or
这真的很酷。所以只是一个小东西，但是，能够做一些不同的事情真的很酷，所以我，是的，我对此感到非常兴奋。你是不是想降档去拍喜剧，然后觉得哦，他妈的好安全感，我觉得很多，你知道我的意思吗？就像你觉得好吧，对啊对啊，或者
let that Clydesdale out of the gate did you get did you get a taste did you get a taste and you're like i got a i want to fucking you know let's let's let's see what else is in there let me keep digging you You know what? I think it's more, I don't think that I, I mean, that's always, that's always alluring, right? Just because you want,
把那匹克莱代尔马放出闸门，你有没有尝到甜头，你有没有尝到甜头，然后觉得我想，你他妈的，你知道的，让我们，让我们，让我们看看里面还有什么，让我继续挖掘。你知道吗？我觉得更像是，我不觉得我，我的意思是，那总是，那总是很有吸引力，对吧？只因为你想，
because if you read something really funny, you're like, oh, that'd be really fun to go fuck around and do that. Right. But at the same time, I think that it is much more about, like, I just, and if it ends up being something that's funny, that's great, I just want to do something that feels,
因为如果你读到一些非常有趣的东西，你会觉得，哦，去胡闹一下一定很有趣。对吧。但与此同时，我觉得这更多的是关于，我只是，如果最后结局是挺有趣的那种，那就太棒了，我只是想做一些感觉，
as you know, it takes, you know, it takes time away from your life and your kids and all that kind of stuff. so it's got to be something that feels valuable. I get to screw around like you guys do with Jason and Sean all the time. So that scratches a lot of itch oddly enough. Right. Yeah, that's actually kind of cool when your quote unquote day job is like riffing with other talented funny friends.
如你所知，这需要，你知道，这会占用你生活、孩子和所有这些的时间。所以它必须是一些有价值的东西。我能像你们经常和杰森、肖恩一起那样胡闹。所以奇怪的是，这满足了我很多心愿。没错。是的，其实这挺酷的，当你的所谓日常工作就是和有才华的搞笑朋友一起即兴创作时。
It's a little spoils you a little where you're like, I don't need to chase this high elsewhere. Yeah, a little bit. Yeah. I hope you've been enjoying the interview with Will Arnett as much as we enjoy. enjoyed doing it. So if you want to hear the second half where we get into Will's morning routine, his kids dunking on him, an extended conversation about Benicio del Toro, then you got to go over to the staying alive feed anywhere you get your podcast. Hit subscribe or follow while you're there. We've got other great conversations with people you'll know and love like Manzukis, Mark Marin,
这有点宠坏了你，让你觉得，我不需要在别处追求这种快感了。是的，有一点。希望你喜欢对威尔·阿奈特的采访，就像我们一样享受。所以如果你想听下半部分，我们聊聊威尔的早晨习惯、他的孩子们对他开玩笑、关于贝尼西奥·德·托罗的深入对话，那你必须去任何你获取播客的地方访问 Staying Alive 的订阅源。去的时候顺便点个订阅或关注。我们还有其他精彩的对话，对象都是你熟知和喜爱的人，比如曼祖基斯、马克·马龙、
Scott Ackerman, Casey Wilson, Ego Wodom, Eric Andre, et cetera, et cetera. Come listen to a very funny people telling us what they do to stay alive. You have been listening to Staying Alive with John Gabris and Adam Pally. A smartless media production in association with Sirius XM. Executive producers are John Gabris, ooh, me, Adam Pally, ooh, you. Will Arnett, Jason Bateman, Sean Hayes, Richard Corson, and Bernie Kaminsky. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
斯科特·阿克曼、凯西·威尔逊、伊戈·乌多姆、埃里克·安德烈等等等等。来听听非常搞笑的人告诉我们他们为了保持生机都做了什么。你一直在收听的是由约翰·加布里斯和亚当·帕利主持的《Staying Alive》。这是一档由 SmartLess 传媒制作、联合 Sirius XM 推出的节目。执行制片人是约翰·加布里斯，哦，我，亚当·帕利，哦，你。威尔·阿奈特、杰森·巴特曼、肖恩·海斯、理查德·科尔森和伯尼·卡明斯基。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。